hey y'all want to give a big THANK YOU
to tik-tok for sponsoring this episode
tik-tok is joining us in celebrating
Asian Pacific American Heritage Month
and we're showcasing the amazing hashtag
AAPI family and the amazing creators and
talent they have Mei is a special month
for us because we ready to just
celebrate the beautiful incredible
creators that are part of the
asia-pacific American community so make
sure you check them out in the link
below with the hashtag 80s guys family
also jubilee we've just launched our own
tick-tock so make sure you check us out
there too without further ado I I don't
I don't dance I don't dance I don't
dance either but I can do that to me the
great hope is that now these little
8-millimeter video recorders and stuff
ik around some just people who normally
wouldn't make movies are gonna be making
them but once the so called
professionalism about movies will be
destroyed forever
I am the tick talker I'm a to talker
I'm a tick talker imma take soccer I'm a
jigsaw I'm a tick talker I'm a chick
talker that's exotic imma take talker
all right what's up good
hey guys doing so I think we should
start with how big or you know just
number of followers and then what kind
of constant we create like the niche
pshhh pshhh okay generally with these
things that the first person to kind of
grasp their attention and to you know
kind of leave the conversation is the
one that kind of gets stay on there long
they can all by screen we have melody
first so melody you want to start sure
Adam was the first one to talk and he
was the one trying to take control of
the situation a little bit I've produced
content more on the basis of Education
I have 58.7 followers and follow rules
for 58000 you guys may need to go faster
oh crap alright for me for me mom I do
comedy on tick-tock and I'm currently at
2.1 2.1 million that's the same thing
5,000 over here 35k he goes occasionally
it was just a hectic first minute when I
get nervous I start talking a lot so I
got aggressive my niche is just doing
weird things that make 10 year olds lock
I do make I do makeup by the way just
the highlight I'm slow you know
okay go ahead and send me who you think
the moles are you'll go for two people
[Music]
Cheyenne I was rooting for you
I like this really didn't get a chance
to talk to the group so I felt kind of
bad in my head I'm like oh maybe if I
spoke for like three seconds less
everyone else is talking a lot more I
don't know who did it so I'm kind of
hurt but okay guys I have some questions
let's do it okay
my strategy for the game was to
basically be the police be the
investigator and when she started asking
a lot of questions that's when I got
really suspicious who has more followers
Charlie or Addison when people gave the
answer first a lot of people followed
what's the national anthem who knows
this one please rise for our national
anthem
open up the safe but just got it back so
the mole started researching tick-tock
you know recently right so can you guys
name some trends for maybe four months
ago the furry versus gamer trend or was
the ego time she got melody I thought
you seemed very eager to prove that she
wasn't a talker
also me to like I did the same thing
you've earned my respect melody I don't
dance either who created the original
ready I was paying attention to all the
trends people knew she did it for the
NBA who's who's Dixie's boyfriend and
you're going to have to select two more
people
so sorry Rahul her lighting setup was
just a little too YouTube her makeup is
so good maybe Jubilee was trying to
trick us by using youtubers maybe I was
intimidating or because I was harsh on
the questions
her makeup like it's alright even we
have a two-way tie between Trevor and
Anna
her name is Anna not Anna my bad I'm
going to set the timer for one minute
and we're going to have a tick-tock
dance-off okay question on Quora says
pitter-patter what sound effect appears
in the actual sound
I promise guys I make take this oh this
is I'm nervous I'm shy on attitude along
with their little brother I'm I promise
I'm sorry huh you know like the worst
part was the fact that like Trevor also
said he didn't know how to dance so it
kind of made me think like okay maybe
I'm not gonna get eliminated I just got
a little suspicious for being a little
bit out of the norm I guess why no
bottom bottom bun right okay raise your
hand if you think that the mole is still
in the game and you want to continue who
is everybody's like favorite creators
Varley oh she's like don't fear varley's
here right
has anyone like had any like encounters
with other tick-tock errs before he
makes tick-tock she's the one who does
my loneliness you guys know somebody
named Arbus en uh her name is aja she's
a really funny Filipino girl she o is a
girl with scoliosis I got a question the
creators know okay when you post the
video generally how is the video scored
I was just I was suspicious you know I
wasn't getting to talk arrives hey Eva
how many followers do you need to go
live oh I'm pretty sure it's 10k because
I'm at 8400 so I'm not able to go live
it okay okay
thank you I'm so sorry I think it's
1,000 yeah that's I asked 1,000
okay I don't know how to go on live
anyway so well you just swipe left so
easy all right well thank you guys I'll
be sure to go on live now I didn't know
how many folders you have to have to go
on live on tape talk
it's a little embarrassing I didn't know
but it's okay raise your hand if you
think the mole is still in the game the
background behind me if it changes red
that means the mole is still in the game
if it changes green that means you got
the mole
what okay if Adams a good liar or not
what white meat
I don't think so you're the only person
I was like what these are they're a
great liar or I look like a [ __ ]
right now a few minutes later and on the
count of three can the moles turn their
cameras on to reveal themselves to
three
oh man you definitely did not expect
angel to be the mole because it seems
like you knew so much about tick-tock
you bamboozled all of us what the heck I
just have to say angel is no longer an
angel in my eyes he played the game so
well I never suspected him for a second
his makeup was incredible I was keeping
a list of people I preached at the top
of not bleep suspicion honestly I've
never had so much anxiety in my life I
really do love tock tick tock is such an
amazing platform I think it's definitely
the future of social media I do know all
the trends like I have a study tick-tock
a lot because of my job and I felt like
I had a really good grasp of it IVA I am
so sorry I came for you I feel like it's
really hard to pinpoint what a to
talkers and what it takes markers and
because tick tock is filled with so many
different kinds of people it's a great
platform to put out a positive message
it's like a big melting pot of different
types of content just getting to do this
on the zoom was really cool everyone was
really nice overall I had a really fun
experience thanks Julie
[Music]